hi um
first of all i wanted to thank you for
coming here i have to say that after
five years of youtube talking to a few
people or a lot of people like me like
mikko and there are many more here i
have to say that i have the chance to
meet them in real life and i also met
extraordinary people here so this is
kind of a very inspiring event
uh especially for me because i didn't
expect
i mean it was really amazing to see all
these people so passionate about
language learning and not only about
language learning
so i thank you duly for coming and so
numerous
now
today's presentation is going to be
about
making languages work for you
i wanted to start with a kind of a
romantic note
um
and
you know i think that love
and passion
are very important in life i want to
show you two simple pictures
the one on the left
is my grandmother
and the one on the right is my
grandfather
they met almost
100 years ago
and
i have to say that these two
are and have been
the inspiration for me
they in my house there were tons of
books
of every field every possible field and
they were she was a math teacher in high
school and
my grandpa was
a rational mechanics professor at
university but their passion was not
just about mathematics it was about
everything it was a passion and thirst
for knowledge
and the amazing thing
when i say that love is everything is
that they passed not only
their knowledge but they passed the the
thirds for knowledge to their sons
and
son
30
years later
my brother
was born
here on the left this is my father
and my sister me and my sister join them
a little bit later
sometimes somebody said that my father
looks a little bit like me i
don't know about that
now um
the the reason why i'm talking about the
fact that they were inspiring figures is
that um they see that something
important to me when i in uh in the
summer my grandmother
she
took me aside i was nine years old and
she told me you know you're going to
high school sorry you're going to middle
school very soon why not study for
example latin and french
you can imagine that summer you want to
go playing with your brothers and
sisters you want to go
swimming in the sea etc but you know
let's reluctant a little bit first but
then i give it a try and i have to say
that these lessons just one hour a day
they changed my way of seeing things and
i was nine
now
like every other italian student at
middle school
i tried to study english
and i also try to study uh french but um
i haven't fallen in love with the
languages because the system at school
you know we normally don't get
in love with language you don't fall in
love with languages
my
my parents decided to hire a private
tutor of english um at the age of
uh 12.
and um what happened is that these two i
call them the hardy boys series it's
it's it's a very simple book what
happened is that um my aunt who also
loves languages and she she is a
wonderful polyglot as well uh she gave
me this book um well one of the books
here the tower treasure it was a very
very simple book
but the thing that struck me is that
immediately after you know leafing
through the book i really wanted to
understand every single word of this
book i remember looking up every single
word
i don't know why but it had spawned some
kind of linguistic monster in me and i
i wanted to learn english so bad that my
parents decided to hire
as i said private tutor and her name is
susan she is from chicago i have to say
she was also another inspiring person
because
she
loved
what she was doing she loved teaching
she loved conveying knowledge
and um
after
middle school
i tried to learn german
i remember i saw a dusty book grammar
book and i tried to figure out
you know
the grammar
german grammar
it was kind of difficult at the
beginning because i was doing it the
wrong way and i didn't know what didn't
work for me so i tried and i tried and
then all of a sudden
um
i
found out the i would call it the luca
method i don't know how to call it's my
method
before showing you what i do uh i would
like to say that for me uh i'm after
some 32 years i just believe and i'm
certain of this that there is no best
language path they're just your language
path
um
here in physics normally when you are a
point a and you want to go to point b
there are many possible paths that you
can follow
um i would like to say that if you
consider the number of people who speak
a lot of languages we have all learned
languages differently
i don't think
any nobody has to learn language the
same way as the other person
so
this is kind of proof that for me there
is no best language the best language
method that people are looking for what
is the best method this is one of the
most asked questions ever
so
um
what i believe and these are very two
very simple steps you have to find your
own language path you have to
find find out what you like
and you have to do something each day
because that's the best way to feed your
brain and to give it knowledge
now um
i call it the luca method but i also
call it the full circle method the
reason why i call i call it the full
circle method it that it consists of two
steps
when you're dealing with a foreign
language you immediately are you're
immediately confronted with something
totally new that you don't understand so
you have to try to figure out
um what the language how the language
works
now it might sound a little bit trivial
but the thing is that you i believe that
in order to learn uh well you have to
make certain that you understand what
you're learning
it might sound very trivial but some
people for example tell me look i've
been learning spanish for three days i
don't understand the radio i said well
you know
the reason why you don't understand the
radio is simply because language you
know connected speech or speaking
language is a flow
so if you don't see the boundaries of
words uh you cannot understand it it
takes time to do that so i think that
it's something progressive and you have
to make certain that you understand what
you're doing all the time some people
just try start learning a language
and then they really don't understand
what they're reading or what they're
listening so i always try to make sure
to have for example bilingual texts so
that i can understand not only you know
the language that i'm trying to figure
out but i i use
my l1 i would say my mother tongue as a
crutch to understand how the other
language works
but um
some people say that listening and
reading
are key to language learning i i believe
that i believe that's the first step
but i also believe that you have to do
something else in order to ingrain the
language in you so what i do normally
i don't start speaking from day one but
i start
you know elaborating the information in
a certain way and i call it synthesis so
every piece of information is first
analyzed and then synthesized so to say
and this is a way to build a foundation
and learning how to assemble the pieces
now um here on the
y-axis you got the efficiency
and here is time as you can see um
once again i want to stress the fact
that this is not universal this is
my way of learning languages there are
some people who immediately start
learning a language for example they go
to a country and they try to learn as
much as they can you know spending many
hours i i don't do that
uh what i do in the beginner phase is i
kind of learn slowly and means that
every day in order to you know there's
there's a very important
thing uh that really counts is the fact
that a lot of people you know you're all
passionate about languages so for you
it's not a problem but for a lot of
people burning out and giving up because
they say well i can't do that you know
it's too difficult it's a serious risk
and the reason why this is a serious
risk is because a lot of people try to
learn too much they spend three four
hours trying because they want to do it
and they believe that the more you do
something
the more you get good at it it's true
but at the beginning your brain
necessarily needs some time to gestate
you know you need some time to
ingrained to get the language in it and
it takes time there's nothing else
there's no way there's no shortcut
you